So let's look at an example of how
a write-back cache would work.
Say we have a small four entry
cache that is direct map.
Each line has a valid bit,
a tag, and a dirty bit.
We don't need the counter,
because in a direct map cache,
we know exactly what to replace.
We don't need counters to tell us that.
Let's say that the processor is
doing this sequence of axises.
And A, B, and
C map to different sets in the cache.
The first axis is right A.
So what we do is we have a miss.
All of our valid bits are 0.
So it doesn't matter what
the rest of the cache has,
because none of the lines are valid.
When we have the first right to A,
we will bring A here.
We will change the value bit to one and
we will change the tag
to correspond to A.
Because this is all right, the
processor,as soon as the data is brought
in will write it and
the dirty bit will be set to one.
Next, we have a read to A.
The processor checks the tag and
the valid bits,
sees that the tag matches A, and the
valid bit is 1, so it can just use A.
The fact that the dirty bit is 1,
doesn't change anything.
Next let's say we have a read B,
we don't find anything that matches B
in the cache, or maybe if this does, the
value of it is 0 so it doesn't matter.
So we will have a miss and
bring B into the cache,
change the tag to correspond to B,
change the value bit to one to indicate
that we do have something here now, and
because this is only a read,
the dirty bit will be 0.
Next let's say we read C.
It's an S, bring C in,
change the tag on the valid bit,
it's a read, so
the dirty bit starts out as 0.
Next what we have is a write To C,
we check if it's a hit and it is.
We write only to the cache and
change the dirty bit to 1.
And now as you can see, the dirty bit
for every line, indicates simply,
was the line ever written, since it
was last brought into the cache?
let's continue this by
an access to E that is RD and
let's say that E maps to where A is.
So now what need to happen is,
we're going to check here
to see whether the tag matches E,
it doesn't so we have a miss.
Our replacement policy is simple,
for direct map caches,
we simply replace whatever is there.
So at this point,
we cannot just bring in E from memory.
First, we have to take the data for
A, that we have written, and
not written to memory yet.
Because the dirty bit is 1, this
block gets sent to memory as a right.
After that happens, we can bring E in,
set the tag and value bit.
And the dirty bit to 0 because
it's a RD, and this continues on.
Let's say that now we have a RD to F,
which replaces B.
Where we want to replace B,
we check the dirty bit is 0, so
B doesn't get sent to memory.
It simply gets overwritten with
a data from F, we fetch, and
because this is a RD,
we get the 0 here, and so on.